it's Miley's new breakup ballad last
night Cyrus released the song slide away
five days after she announced she and
Liam were over and fans are trying to
decode it
[Music]
remember Miley left her house in the
city to move in with Hemsworth near the
ocean in Malibu and then there's these
lyrics multiple reports blamed Liam's
alleged drinking and partying ways for
the break-up our source denied those
claims but Miley writes about not
wanting alcohol and drugs even posting
this image to accompany the track
besides her admitted past sobriety
struggles there's more of our imitating
life I'm 17 I'm like I'm gonna have a
boyfriend
yeah she's talking about Liam they met
on the set of the last song and were
dogged by the paparazzi kind of stinks
if you are gonna take a vacation and
people are you know snapping fingers so
it's kind of look weird I guess for Liam
and I to experience that together cut -
last weekend fotox were focused on
another romantic vacation this is the
lovely Caitlyn Carter yesterday Brody
Jenner's ex didn't mention her Italian
rendezvous with Cyrus at a live podcast
her fellow Hills star Whitney Port
today Brody's defending Caitlyn slamming
negativity directed at her he still
calls Caitlyn his best friend but on
Mondays the hills new beginnings it's
clear they didn't see eye to eye on
having kids I wouldn't mind waiting how
many years are we gonna say this
[Music]